The Joe Rogan experience.
Okay.
I always wondered about that.
Um,
the catch a Predator show.
Yeah.
Why the fuck would they sign for it?
They have to sign a release.
Do they?
Yes.
Or cops.
They have to sign a release that you have to sign a release.
So yeah.
And then there's like the,
is it entrapment even,
you know,
there was that whole thing too.
Well that show's definitely entrapment.
Yeah,
but it's entrapment.
I support.
Yeah,
totally.
I support and treatment.
If it's like,
yeah,
Hey,
do you want to fuck a six year old?
And they're like,
Yo,
do okay.
Get in the cage fucking piece of shit.
That's right.
Yeah.
This is certainty trapping them the for you in the fucking,
anybody under 18,
right?
Or,
yeah,
I have.
Do they get away with that?
How do they get to show it in their face?
Maybe because it,
they were proven guilty.
You waived your rights,
but just by being guilty,
you have no rights when your fellow.
Right.
Thank you.
Andrew Sandlin you have no rights.
Is that right?
Well,
you have rights.
Bernie Sanders wants you to be able to vote,
even if you're a terrorist.
If you've seen that,
he's like,
yeah,
anybody in jail for anything?
He's was like,
you should still be able to vote.
I'm like,
Ooh.
Okay.
I don't know.
It's a lot of people in jail.
That's true.
What if they count as residents of the state?
Like what have you have like a maximum security prison somewhere.
Right.
And these prisoners have everything too,
like they have all day,
right?
Yeah.
You know what I need to do?
And they register to vote while they're in there.
If you have a few hundred thousand prisoners.
Yeah.
You literally can shift an election one way or the other.
That's true.
All you don't have to do is get into that prison and go,
hey guys,
here's the deal.
Um,
I'm,
I'm for shortening your fucking sentences.
Okay?
Yeah.
I'm forgetting you better lawyers.
People would start campaigning and prisons.
That's legit,
man.
Yeah.
These laws were bullshit.
And you can bribe him real easy with the little ketchup,
cigarettes,
bringing cigarettes.
Can you just trucking cartons of cigarettes?
How do you win this election?
Marlboro reds.
What's that guy's name?
Booted.
Judge a judge.
What's his name?
How do you say his name?
Telsey.
Gabbers my girl.
I'm voting for her.
I decided I liked her.
I met her in person cause I don't know.
I give up,
I give up.
I'm not even paying attention to anything else.
Tell scabbard uh,
but um,
if you could go into a prison,
like what is a,
what's a B?
What's a giant prison population?
What's big biggest one?
Well,
no,
we think the biggest one is biggest one.
Uh,
I don't know,
but to be in New York,
California,
there was that,
what a,
isn't there a giant one in Colorado that Joey was talks about?
They take the serial killers,
they stuff them on the ground,
isn't there?
Um,
what is the,
what's the biggest one?
Uh,
take 50,004.
He looks at it.
Okay.
Did you say 50,000 prisoners?
Yeah.
I don't know much about that.
That's probably a lot of people think about it around spread football arena,
right?
Yeah,
it's all that's true.
Okay.
Well No.
50 to 60,000.
The biggest one?
The biggest?
Yeah.
What's the smile?
It's one of,
it's probably some eldest rinky dinky.
Yeah.
But I bet I'm gonna stay in jail.
No.
Yeah,
I'm gonna say a little lighter.
I'm going to say 30,000.
Dirham say 30,000.
The biggest or they put money on this.
I'll put a dollar on this.
I don't give a fuck bro.
I put I'll bet Ya Heineken double zero shit.
Now that we've got to raise from my blood,
what do we got?
Jimmy's confused.
I have to be very specific about what I look up to find this answer.
So do you want largest maximum security?
Sure.
Yeah.
Killers.
Not People who smoke weed,
uh,
known as Alcatraz of the south.
The Louisiana state penitentiary would go,
has an inmate population of 5,000.
That's it.
That's maximum security.
So like criminals,
if you go a little bit less than it might be a little bit higher,
but okay,
let's go with thieves.
Let's go with medium security or maximum is like violent crimes.
Biggest prison.
Yeah,
the biggest prison.
The largest prison.
That's the thing that popped up.
And that's a luxury before way off 5,000 people.
It looks bigger.
ADX and Florence,
the supermax prison,
if there's one old supermax prison,
that's the one I think you're talking about,
that's even higher.
But that would probably have way less people trying to see if it says,
oh,
that's even higher criminal level.
Yeah.
That was like where they put the ice 23 hours a day talking about single cell
confinement.
Um,
5,000 is a lot of people can find me this so weird cause like where'd you were
killing you?
But we're just killing you with nature.
We're going to kill you with old age and shitty nutrition.
You just can keep you in a box with your own brain.
No.
Weird.
Yeah.
It's like,
it might be more cruel to put someone into a small cage for 23 hours a day then
this to just kill them.
I think so.
Yeah.
If you just kill you,
it's over with.
Yeah.
You're still suffering.
Hundred percent.
Yeah.
100%.
Like that was,
uh,
my,
my take on,
uh,
Chelsea Manning,
who's now free.
Yeah.
Like they tortured her.
They tortured.
They did?
Yeah.
She was naked in the cage by herself for years.
I think it was like the,
the whole,
she was in solitary.
We'll have to find this out once Jamie's tell him with this search,
I'm like looking around.
There's a,
the one that California's male only where Manson is,
it's got 3,500 there's one in Illinois,
medium security.
It's got a thousand.
Okay,
so wait,
we're way off by a factor of,
you're so pessimistic thought it was going low and I was off by a factor of 10 I
don't know if this is counting then through those private ones,
and I don't know if I can get the numbers on private,
those dirty bastards stuff and then on top of each other,
it makes sense.
If there were 30,000 inmates in one place,
a man,
it would be hard to contain that and control that.
Yeah.
What's the largest private prison?
See if that's
okay.